die lage ist sehr gut
neues album raus pentax schon wieder
lateinisch richtig wie der lateinisch
wieder ein stilelement benutzen wie so
oft ich find's einfach cool
ich bin nicht mal der lateinischen
sprache fließend mächtig so es geht
einfach darum ich finde es geil wenn die
leute noch mal hingehen müssen nicht
direkt auf den ersten blick wissen worum
es geht also geld müssen sich schon mit
dem gedanken also mit dem titel
auseinander sind vermissen sich gedanken
machen was da auf sie zukommt oder was
da auf sie wartet und ich denke das gibt
noch mal so ein anreiz ein bisschen die
spannung zu steigern so und ich finde es
ganz gut dass du irgendwann mal
eingeführt und ich bleibe jetzt der
bericht in troja wenn und pax lateinisch
heißt krieg und frieden ist das auch so
ein bisschen das motto für das alkohol
also eine gute mischung aus songs wurde
einfach nur bescheuert spielen sollte
und nicht viel nachdenken sonst und auf
der anderen seite natürlich auch wie man
das von mir ein bisschen kennt so die
dinge wo man auf jeden fall aussage oder
zum nachdenken angeregt wird also nicht
dumpf einfach nur bedienen so ich
persönlich bin der meinung aber das ist
nur meine persönliche meinung dass dinge
wie brennpunkt familien im brennpunkt
familien dort familien hier junge frau
sucht model model sucht biest das finde
ich persönlich perverser weil die ganzen
leute sitzen abends soll trotzdem so
pumpen sich das rein und uns wird
vorgegeben ist sehr real so das ist das
schlimmste ich glaube ganz ehrlich ich
mittlerweile hat das auch jeder so ein
bisschen durchschaut aber trotzdem
ziehen sich einfach viele rein weil es
einfach unterhaltung für die darstellt
und da sind wir bei einem punkt
unterhaltung so was ich gerade gesagt
habe unser humor hin geht so ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob man jetzt ist eine maß
mit dem anderen messen kann so das
sollte überhaupt nur ich finde es ganz
ähnlich einfach perverser wenn du jetzt
sage ich toleriere die ganze scheiße dem
fernsehen läuft zum beispiel diese
vollidioten bei dschungelcamp also ich
meine was was es daran noch roman wenn
jemand da hingeht und für geld irgendwie
scheiße frist die kein normaler mensch
essen würde weise einfach im prinzip
beginn den normalen prinzipien eines
menschen verstößt
scheiße von irgendeinem tier zu essen
ganz einfach andere möglichkeiten das
internet lässt alles noch weiter
zusammenwachsen ich meine wenn man auf
facebook ich habe zum beispiel 600.000
likes auf meiner seite
auch wenn facebook viele dicht macht
trotzdem wenn man etwas öl teilt neues
video das ist ja wie so ein virus der
sich verbreitet so und dadurch kommen
leute mit rap in berührung oder
entdecken das für sich die vielleicht
vorher gar nicht die möglichkeiten
hatten weil ich meine das tv format ist
ja längst überholt und da über die
musiksender brauchen wir gar nicht zu
sprechen so das ja noch
gute frage nächste kleine hat sie
gesehen keiner hat sie gesehen
entspricht noch darüber
über die geschichte so und deswegen
denke ich dass es auch von vorteil ist
man sich selber besser präsentieren
können und die leute das gefühl bzw
die leute das alles nachvollziehen
können wenn du den erhalt so eindrücke
gibt und die mit erwachsenen so und ich
denke das ganze hat sie schon vor 45
jahren abgespielt und jetzt siehst du
halt dass diese leute älter werden und
web halt mit wächst um ein busfahrer hat
war der gleiche der seinen seine tour
gefahren hat und der dann zufällig ein
altes album von mir die ganze zeit
laufen lassen
doch irgendwann war redmond hat das die
ganze mitbekommen zugehört so nebenbei
unbewusst und immer noch natürlich
bewusst jahre hatte gerd der connect uns
nur irgendwie mit den typen kohl nein
wäre doch so hat das eine das andere
wort gegeben und wir haben natürlich uns
ich habe mich natürlich nicht zweimal
bitten dass man kommt rum oder sozial
show wir haben es auf anhieb gut
verstanden und dann haben wir das ding
hochgeht
ja wir sind halt bei der tour das album
ist am start ich hoffe dass die leute
rein hören werden so ein gutes ding
geworden
schauen wir mal vielen dank ich denke
viele war alles klar